the most terrible events in the history of
mankind took place when he was
faced with something
unknown
frightening
today in the south of the capital you can observe a
rare cosmic phenomenon, not that I
'm in a hurry, just following the stars will
be in fifty years
for Madame, a big man like they
came to admire the west and  on a
truly bewitching
people for thousands of years have been waiting for contact with
an alien civilization an hour ago in the
metropolitan hell
I went to us what betrayed
your volume should depend on how they
behave choke on
weapons but why they flew in we have no idea
what moral standards they have come to but I have long been
explaining to them fashion  because this is a
unique chance for all of humanity to
understand something about ourselves, to find out who
we all the time don’t understand the impulse
if we don’t want to go down in history, as if
we provoke an explosion, then no history,
as you show, can be
at all who we don’t attack
our land is
ours  the earth
and another galaxy, and we are with hell